but that's the problem no I mean if you
think about that here's what if you
think about that this is what it seems
like it's happening
you said gold exchange of rate us
obviously the currency in a long term
interest rates and and I'll get to
second part of the question here is in
order for the person to do the right
thing so let's just say we know what the
right thing is to campaign on okay so
imagine I'm running for office and this
is my campaign we need to stop spending
money we need to have the 40% of
businesses that are to be you know
people that don't have the finances in
order some of these guys need to get
filtered out we need to figure out a way
to pay off our debt and in doing so we
need to raise the taxes we need no one's
gonna vote for this person look yes
freedom capitalism Liberty is a lousy
campaign slogan people don't vote for
freedom they vote for free stuff that is
the problem look the founding fathers
knew this that's why America was created
as a republic they knew if we were a
democracy we would collapse
so they protected us from democracy with
the Republican form of government that
they created and they and they bound the
government in the chains of the
Constitution and it worked for a long
time we were incredibly free throughout
the 19th century I mean the most
prosperous period of America of American
history of world history was probably
the end of the Civil War - the beginning
of the first world war that's when we
had the smallest government the purest
gold standard we really were you know
following the Constitution and and we
prospered but yes you know it is very
difficult when now everybody is voting
and the government in particular has
crippled so many people and now they
have the crutch and people don't realize
that they're crippled because of the
government all they see is the
government offering a crutch and they
want that crutch and look you know you
could look at look at the example of
student loans I mean this is one of the
most obvious examples of a government
created problem I ran for Senate in
Connecticut in 2010 and you know I was
against student loans I wanted to
abolish all government guaranteed
student loans and all student loans
and you know before the government got
involved in student loans which it
didn't always bill it really started
with the GI Bill in the Second World War
but that was just you know to help the
soldiers who were returning from the war
they really started getting involved in
the 60s so before that you know if you
wanted to go to college you just paid
for and it wasn't expensive College
believe it or not was not expensive
before the government came in to help
make it affordable if your parents were
relatively rich they just wrote a check
you know if they were upper-class you
know if your parents were lower middle
class or middle class maybe you got a
summer job that's what my dad did my dad
went to college he grew up his parents
were relatively poor he worked his way
through college like most of his friends
by waiting tables over the summer that's
it he graduated college no debt right
and he you know and he lived away from
home but he was able to earn enough just
getting tips on a summer job to to put
himself through college but what
happened is a bunch of politicians came
to the students in the 1960s and said
you shouldn't have to work over the
summers you should enjoy your summers
you should be go to the beach and having
fun will let you borrow the money right
to go to college and just pay it back
after you graduate when you have a
better job and you can earn more money
and the students work oh that sounds
great I can have fun this summer I don't
have to work the government's gonna give
me this loan now of course without the
government guarantees the students
couldn't borrow the money because they
had no collateral
what bank is gonna loan money to an
eighteen year old you know so I they
couldn't have got the loans but once the
government guaranteed the loans then
anybody could get the loans so the
minute the kids had all this money to go
to college and bit up the prices the
universities were like oh wow we can
really raise prices now because the
students can borrow the money from the
government and give it to us so the
minute the government started
guaranteeing student loans tuition is
started to explode and then as the
tuition got higher and higher the
government had to provide bigger and
bigger loans to pay for it and then it
became a self-perpetuating spiral the
more money the government made available
to students
the higher the tuition got to the point
that now
the students are graduating with a
crippling amount of debt whereas they
used to graduate debt-free when the
government wasn't involved at all now
they're graduating with massive debt and
the irony of it is you see these
Democrats right in these debates
pointing to this huge problem without
admitting that the government is the
only reason those student loans exist
without those student loans College
would be cheap and students wouldn't
have any debt but because of government
interference the cost of a college
degree went through the roof and because
everybody has a college degree now
they're worth nothing before the
government was involved most people
didn't go to college a high school
degree was all you needed now because
everybody goes you need a heist you need
a college degree to do what you used to
be able to do with a high school degree
now you got to get a masters or a PhD
but by the time you borrow all the money
to get that and you're in school into
your early 30s right you're in debt up
to your eyeballs all this is because of
government now what are these guys
saying are they saying oh we really
screwed up here we had good intentions
but the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and now we need to get
government out of the student loan
business completely we need to have free
market capitalism working so that
colleges are under competitive pressures
to control their costs to get customers
like everybody no no no now the solution
is completely nationalize it have the
government pay for college
let's make College free let's forgive
all the loans so now they want to make
college even more expensive by making it
free right the most expensive things are
the stuff you get from the government
for free so they first they jacked up
the cost by subsidizing it now they want
to make it even more expensive by
providing it for free they did the same
thing with housing you know they do the
same thing with health care every aspect
of the economy that the government gets
involved in they screw it up they make
the price go up and the quality go down
whereas when the free market is involved
the opposite happens prices go down and
quality goes up but I gotta finish the
point I was making on the choice that
the Fed has either they do the right
thing and let interest rates go up and
the whole house of cards that they've
been building crashes down or
don't do that because it's too
politically difficult and they just
print money they just continue to QE
they bailout everybody and they destroy
the dollar and then the dollar is
worthless and that if they do that right
a hyperinflation is much worse
economically than just a massive
economic collapse right the pain that
that will inflict is gonna be far
greater but because it may happen six
months or a year later or two years
later who knows that may be the course
that we end up not taking so again
everything you said let's just say
common sense let's take common sense
make the government smaller you know uh
you know figure out a way to not spend
the kind of money with school loans
where the government's not involved in
the school loans let the private folks
do it you don't get involved so we don't
have to have the what's the number today
one trillion dollars a trillion one 401
it's somewhere on there trillion tour
surely in three we have college debt
right oh yeah it's like more than that
yeah let's just say it's everything
you're saying
common sense somebody watching says okay
this makes sense I get it but I want to
go solutions I want to go next phase I
talked to a guy at AIG we were having a
debate because I've been asking these
guys to make some adjustments on their
technology and they keep saying Pat you
know we're working on it were working on
it this was like four years ago finally
one of the guys who's a quality guy
trust them he said look you have to
realize who you're doing business with I
said what's that he said this is AIG I
said I know I've been doing business
with you guys for Dickey now he says
we're so big that when you want to
launch a new adjustment to a software or
a technology it's not like a small
business owner entrepreneur that's
nimble to say let's make the change it's
gonna take you know 60 days yeah all
right here's what I'm good this let me
wrap up the question here we're saying
okay let's make the government smaller
you got seven and a half eight million
employees that are governor employees
you got the military you got all these
people that are working you're always
different EP all these departments that
yep how do you make the government
smaller on one term or two term so again
this leads to the next question is you
got one term two-term president then you
got Republican President Bush senior
then you got
Linton then you got Bush then you got
Obama then you got Trump then you got
you know you say yeah Cuomo gets elected
one philosophy doesn't stay long enough
for us to be able to pay off this that
it's about what campaigns get it gets us
real like it that's not gonna be paid
off but we have to be honest about that
we can't even solve the problems and
whisper honest about the situation so
the debts are not gonna be repaid the
question is is it better to inflate them
away or default
I think default is better I think a
legitimate bankruptcy and restructuring
is better hey look we loaded all the
kids up with debt yes students have much
too much debt we cannot expect them to
repay it but we can't solve the problem
unless we first say okay no more
government involvement in college we it
was a mistake and and colleges are gonna
have to compete in the free market for
students no government guaranteed loans
no government direct loans we we have to
go back to capitalism in order for the
solutions to work the solutions will
work now people are gonna lose money
because if loans are not repaid then the
lenders are gonna test suffer a loss
that has to happen but you know when you
talk about making government smaller yes
the government's gonna have to lay off a
lot of government workers that doesn't
mean those people are gonna be
unemployed forever
that means the resources that were
required to employ them are now freed up
back to the private sector the private
sector is going to use those resources
more efficiently and more productively
than the government so whenever the
government cuts spending right and and
including laying off government workers
now the private sector has more money to
employ those workers productively in
fact a lot of government workers not
only are they not productive they
actually work reducing the productivity
of everybody else
so it's like the people who are actually
producing they are less productive
because of all these bureaucrats getting
in their way
so you know the bureaucrats are riding
in the wagon and the rest of us are
trying to pull it if the people who are
riding in the wagon not only jump out
but help us pull right then we're gonna
make a lot more progress that wagons
gonna be a lot easier we're you know
taking a lot further so there's there's
a lot of light at the end of a
free-market tunnel but first you've got
to get over that hump
of letting voters know that you know yes
if you if you died an exercise I know
it's not going to be fun but you're
gonna be healthier you're gonna have a
better life you're gonna live longer you
know if you just do this if you just
follow this program so capitalism is
gonna take us to where we want to go
socialism never will it's it's a false
promise that we're just gonna solve this
problem with more government but you
know the other problem is you know so
many Americans have been brainwashed in
government schools they don't understand
free-market capitalism they just see the
problems in the economy and assume that
they're a function of free market
capitalism when they're not and they
think that more government is the
solution to a problem that they don't
understand was created by government and
by making government bigger we're just
gonna make the problems big
[Music]